allez à la noyade et bnda sens chaque
fois que je viens jouer à gauche c'est
pareil quand pas défendre il faudrait le
faire jouer sa parole m d'autres rôles
du répertoire que vous avez joué aussi
longue et blick c'est lui qui s'énerve
alors vous ne bougez pas toi que j'ai
joué aussi l'enfant and on and on suit
la pensée ça c est à cac c'est
exceptionnel je pense que je suis acteur
du français qui l'a le plus qui va le
plus juteuses les jouets 200 250 fois à
paris sur les 2 sur les deux mises en
scène dont celle de mocassins de aussi
de molière avec elle michel aumont a
servi pour les grands mais son rôle
fétiche celui il accompagne tout au long
de sa vie d'ailleurs c'est harpagon et
pourtant malgré la longue fréquentation
de ce personnage à la passion extrême
toujours ce tract qui nous cette tension
avant de rentrer en scène
a changé il ya encore une chose qui
m'inquiète la fille jeunes comme tu vois
les jeunes gens d'ordinaire un chef mais
une peur semblables ne cherchent que
leurs compagnies j'ai peur un homme de
mon âge ne soit pas de son goût cela ne
vienne à produire chez moi j'attends un
petit désordre qui de mac au maghreb
vous la connaissez mal c'est encore une
particularité que j'avais à vous dire
elle a une aversion épouvantable pour
les jeunes gens l'amour que pour les
vieillards
voilà on est parti pour vingt ans enfin
espérons